they say things about Islam which are
alien to Islam it does not exist in
Islam for
example many critics say that Islam is
an unscientific
religion just to give you one example
time will not permit me to give several
examples since nowadays we're having a
controversy on the famous Bangladeshi
writer
tasin she
says that the Quran mentions that the
sun revolves around the earth and if we
have to believe in such an outdated book
How can the Muslims
advance and I challenge anyone to point
out any verse of the Quran which says
that the sun rolv around the
earth and I said this several years back
when I had a debate about
her in the bom of
journalist what she's referring to is a
verse of the Quran which I quoted
earlier in my talk inia chapter number
21 verse number 33 which
says it is Allah who has created the
night and the day the Sun and the
Moon each one traveling in its own Orit
so here the Quran says that the sun is
revolving in
motion nowhere does the Quran say that
the sun is revolving around the earth
it's her own understanding her own
interpretation the word Earth is not
there in the verse of the
Quran the Quran says it is revolves in a
motion which I explained earlier the
Quran says besides revolving it also
rotates when I was in school I didn't
know about
that and now science has testified that
so many time the critics of Islam they
say things about Islam which are alien
to
Islam
and very
often fourth strategy
used they mention things about Islam and
after that they say that because of this
Islam is the problem for
Humanity today the problem that we have
in the
world is mainly because of Islam and
they say Muslims are terrorists they are
fundamentalist they extremist Islam is
an intolerant religion because of all
these
things Islam is a problem for Humanity
and many a time we Muslims
apologetic which I would rather use the
strategy of turn the tables
over and today Muslims are called as
fundamentalist what is the meaning of
the word fundamentalist fundamentalist
by definition means a person who follows
the fundamentals of one particular field
for example if a person wants to be a
good mathematician he should know follow
and practice the fundamentals of math
unless he's a fundamentalist in the
field of math he cannot be a good
mathematician for a person
to be a good scientist he should know
follow and practice the fundamentals of
science unless he is a fundamentalist in
the field of science he cannot be a good
scientist you cannot paint all
fundamentalist with the same brush that
all are good or all are bad depending in
which field the person is a
fundamentalist you have to label him
accordingly for
example if we have a fundamentalist
robber whose profession is to Rob he's
bad for the society he's a ban for the
society on the other hand if you have a
fundamentalist doctor who saves hundreds
of human lives he's a boon for the
society you can't paint all
fundamentalist with the same brush that
all are good or all are bad depending in
which field is the person of
fundamentalist you have to label him
accordingly as far as I'm
concerned I am a fundamentalist Muslim
and I am proud to be a fundamentalist
Muslim because I
know I
strive and I follow the principles of
Islam and I know that there is not a
single fundamental of Islam not a single
teaching of Islam which is Against
Humanity as a whole there may be a few
teachings of Islam which some non-muslim
May feel are Against Humanity but the
moment you give the logical reasoning
the
statistics behind the teaching there is
not a single human being who's unbiased
who can point out a single fundamental
of Islam which is Against Humanity as a
whole and this word
fundamentalism was first coined
according to the weer dictionary it was
used to describe the Protestant
Christians in the early part of the 20th
century in America so this word first
was used for the
Americans for the Protestant
Christians because they protested
against the church the church believe
that the message of the Bible was from
God these Protestant Christians they
protested that not only is the message
of the Bible from God every word every
letter of the Bible is from
God if someone can prove that every
letter every word of the Bible is from
God this fundamentalism movement it's a
good
movement on the other hand if someone
can prove that every word of the Bible
is not from almighty God then this
movement is not a good
movement when we read the Oxford
dictionary we find
out and it says that fundamentalist is a
person who strictly aders to to the
ancient doctrine of any
religion but when I read one of the
revised addition of Oxford dictionary
there was a site change it says that
fundamentalist is a person who strictly
aderes to the ancient doctrine of any
religion especially
Islam so especially Islam has been added
in the revised edition of Oxford
dictionary the
moment you see a Muslim
your mind goes that he's a
fundamentalist and we Muslims apologetic
I'm not a fundamentalist I say I'm a
fundamentalist what is the
problem you cannot be a good Muslim
until you are a fundamentalist
Muslim the media says Muslims are
extremist I see yes I'm an extremist I'm
extremely kind I'm extremely loving I'm
extremely merciful I'm extremely honest
I'm extremely
just what's wrong in being extremely
kind extremely merciful extremely loving
extremely just extremely honest you
can't be partly honest when it benefits
you you're honest when it does not
benefit you you aren't honest according
to the Quran you have to be extremely
kind extremely merciful if you are a
Muslim you have to be an extremist
Muslim you have to be extremely kind you
you have to be extremely honest you have
to be extremely just I
want a single human being to tell me
what is wrong in being extremely
honest you have to be extremist in the
right direction we Muslims should not be
apologetic no no no I'm a moderate
Muslim what's a moderate
Muslim you either follow Islam or don't
follow
Islam Allah says in the
Quran enter into wholeheartedly Surah
Bak 2 verse number
208 you can't down to follow part of
Islam you have to be fully just you have
to be fully honest extremely
honest if every human being becomes the
fundamentalist Muslim following the
fundamentals of Islam the problems of
humanity will be solved if every human
being is an extremist Muslim extremely
kind extremely loving extremely honest
extremely just the problem of Humanity
will be
solved today Muslims are given the label
that Muslims are
terrorist many a time two different
labels are given to the same
individual for the same activity for
example 60 years back 70 years back
there were many Indians who were
fighting for the freedom of the country
when the britishers were ruling
India these Indians by the British
government they were called as
terrorist but the same people for the
same activity we common Indians we call
them as Freedom Fighters as
Patriots same people same activity two
different labels if you agree with the
view of the British government that they
had a right rule over India then you
have to call these Indians are terrorist
but if you agree with the view of the
common Indians that the britishers came
to India to do business
they have no right to rule over us then
you'll call these people as Freedom
Fighters as Patriots same people same
activity two different
labels and we find several such examples
in history
several we know during the American
Revolution in
775 when the britishers when that
occupied
America there were many Americans who
were fighting for the freedom and number
one terrorist according to the British
British government was George
Washington George Washington by the
British government was called as number
one terrorist in
775 later
on he becomes the president of America
USA imagine terrorist number one become
the president of
USA and he happens to be the Godfather
of all the presidents to come including
George
Bush
and what are my comments on George Bush
you can see my tape terrorism and Jihad
and Islamic
perspective and we find several such
examples before South Africa was free it
was ruled by the white aparted
government this white aparted government
had imprisoned Nelson Mandela for more
than 25 years in Robin islands and they
said that he was terrorist number
one later on after the aparted
government was removed in South Africa
when the new government came they
released Nelson Mandela and later on he
got the Nobel Prize for Peace imagine
terrorist number one getting Nobel Prize
for Peace not that he was bad and then
he became good not that he killed many
people and then he became good for the
same activity for which he was called
terrorist number one he was given the
Nobel Prize for
Peace so what we come to know today it's
in the hands of the media whoever is in
power whatever label they give to a
person it gets
stuck whether it's the truth or not that
is secondary whoever is in power who has
control of the
media what they portray about a person
that label gets stuck to that person
therefore before giving a label first
you have to identify for what reason
that person was striving and then give
the
label and Quran clearly
mentions in Surah MAA chapter number 5
verse number 32 that if anyone kills any
other human being unless it be for
murder or for spreading corruption in
the land it is as though he has killed
the whole of humanity most of the
religion say that killing innocent human
being is wrong Quran goes a step further
and says that if you kill any innocent
human being it is as though you have
killed the whole of humanity and it does
not stop there it goes further and says
that if you save any human life it is as
though you have saved the whole of
humankind most of the religious
scriptures do say you should not care in
to human being Quran goes a step further
and says that if you kill any innocent
human being you have killed the whole of
humanity and if you have saved any human
being you have saved the whole of
humanity yet
Islam is called as an intolerant
religion and I do say that Islam
is an intolerant religion Islam is
intolerant towards corruption Islam is
intolerant towards Injustice Islam is
intolerant towards discrimination Islam
is intolerant towards dishonesty Islam
is intolerant towards racism Islam is
intolerance towards victimization it is
an intolerant
religion see
theoretically all the countries say that
dishonesty is wrong
all the
countries and all the religions they say
corruption is wrong all of the people
they say discrimination is wrong they
say racism is wrong they say
victimization is wrong but that is only
a theory in most of the countries most
of the countries have
corruption there dishonesty in most of
the countries so just because Islam is
intolerant towards the
practices which are prevalent in many
countries I do agree Islam is an
intolerant religion Islam is intolerant
towards those things which almighty God
knows are wrong for the human being
which
today many human beings feel it is a
part and parcel of society they think if
you do these things you are
Advanced so Islam is intolerant to those
things which the Creator feels is wrong
and many of the human means today feel
are right Islam is intolerance towards
alcoholism Islam is intolerance towards
drug addiction towards porography
towards prostitution towards adultery
towards
fornication Islam is an intolerant
religion it's intolerant towards the
evils of the
society
because if you're intolerant towards
these
things then only will you have the
solution to the problems of
humanity many people go on the defense
oh Islam is not an intolerant religion
it is intolerant towards the
wises but tolerant towards the things
which are
good it does not force anyone at the
point of the Sal Allah says in the Quran
in Surah Bak chap 2 verse
256 there's no compulsion in
religion many people quote this and put
a full stop that's not the end of the
verse the verse
continues there's no compulsion religion
truth stands out clear from error you
have to present the truth if you want to
accept it accept it if you don't want to
accept it no problem no one can force
you to accept Islam at the point of the
sword or the point of the
gun in this way it is the most tolerant
religion when we
analyze most of the
religions they speak good things so
what's the difference between Islam and
the other religions the difference
between Islam and the other religions is
that Islam besides speaking good things
it shows you a way how to achieve the
state of goodness for
example most of the religion say that
you should not
Rob Hinduism says that Christianity says
that Islam says the same so what is the
difference between Islam and the other
religions the difference is Islam
besides saying that you should not rob
it shows you a way how to achieve that
state in which people will not
Rob Islam has a system of zakat one of
the pillars of Islam is zakat that every
rich person who has a saving of more
than the nisab level more than 85 gram
of gold he or she should give
2.5% of that wealth every lunar year in
charity to the poor people if every Rich
human being gives charity gives zakat
poverty will be eradicated from this
world there will not be a single human
being who will die of
hunger
yet even after no human being will die
of hunger yet there are people who yet
want to
Rob to get wealth
easily to fulfill the desires which are
wrong Islam has a solution for that also
after zakat almighty God says in the
Quran in Surah MAA chapter number 5
verse number 38 as to the thief be it a
man or a woman chop off his or her hand
as a punishment from Allah subhana tala
non-muslims will say chopping of the
hands in this 21st century Islam is a
barbaric religion it's a ruthless way of
life and they think that every second
person you come across in Saudi Arabia
where this law is practiced you will
find that every second person will have
his hand chopped
off I've been to Saudi Arabia several
times more than 20 30 times never have I
come across a single human being whose
hands have been chopped off surely there
will be some people whose hands may have
been chopped off but the law is so
strict a person will think a million
times
before robbing not that the police of
Saudi Arabia is very intelligent but the
law is so
strict that the moment you implement the
law you get
results the moment you make the law easy
if this law is relaxed in Saudi Arabia
robber will start in Saudi Arabia
also and
today we look up to
America as a country which is most
advanced do you know it is a country
which has one of the highest rate of
theft and
robbery I'm asking the question that if
if you implement the Islamic Sharia in
America in USA that every rich person
who has a saving of more than 85 grams
of gold should give 2.5% of his excess
wealth in charity and after that if any
person robs chop off his or her hand I'm
asking the question will the rate of
theft and robbery in America will it
increase will it remain the same or will
it
decrease it will decrease it's a
practical law it is not a very
intelligent question that you have
answered it is simple logic
you implement the Shar and you get
results so Islam is the only solution to
the problems of
humankind let me give you one more
example most of the religions they say
that it should not molest a woman that
it should not rape a woman Hinduism says
that Christianity says that Islam says
the same so what's the difference
between Islam and the other religions
the difference is ISL
besides saying that you should not
molest a woman that it should not rape a
woman it shows you a way in which you
can achieve a society in which there
will be no molestation there will not be
any
rape Islam speaks about the system of
hijab most of the people talk about the
hijab for the women but almighty God in
the Quran first speaks about the hijab
for the man and then for the woman Allah
says in the Quran in Surah n chapter
number 24 verse number 30 say to the
believing man that whenever he looks at
a woman if any Breen thought comes any
unem thought comes he should lower his
G there was a Muslim
person Muslim man who was staring at a
girl for a long time I told him brother
what are you doing it's not allowed in
Islam so he told me our beloved Prophet
said that the first glance Is Forgiven
the second is prohibited I have not
completed my first glance
what did the prophet mean that the first
glance Is Forgiven the second is
prohibited that does not mean you can
look at a woman for 10 minutes without
blinking and saying I have not completed
my
glance what the prophet meant that
unintentionally if you look at a woman
do not look at her
again to Feast on her
beauty the next verse speaks about the
hijab for the woman almighty God says in
Surah n chapter number 24 verse number
31 Allah says that say to the believing
woman that she should lower a Gaz and
guard a modesty and display not a beauty
except what appears ordinary off and
draw her head
covering over a bom and display not of
beauty except in front of her father her
brother a husband and a big list of meam
the Clos relatives which she cannot
marry is given in short there are six
criteria for hijab mentioned in the
Quran and the Hadith of the Prophet
malli wasallam the first is the extent
for the man it from the NV to the knee
for the woman the complete body should
be covered the only part that can be
seen are the face and hands up to the
wrist the remaining five criteria are
the same for the man and the woman the
second is the clothes they wear it
should not be tight so that it reveals
the figure third it should not be
translucent or transparent so that you
can see through the clothes the fourth
the clothes should not be So Glamorous
so that it attracts the opposite sex
fifth it should not resemble that of the
unbeliever and sixth it should not
resemble that of the opposite
sex and the Quran says in Surah aab
chapter number 33 verse number 59 oh
Prophet tell your wives your daughters
and the believing women that when they
go abroad they should put on the jilbab
they should put on theat overclo so that
they shall be recognized and it will
prevent them from being molested the
Quran says hijab had been prescribed for
the wom so that they shall be recognized
their modest and it will prevent the
from being
molested I would like to ask a simple
question that
Suppose there are twin sisters who are
very beautiful who are equally beautiful
and one of them she's wearing the
western clothes mini skirts or shorts
and the other twin sister she's wearing
the Islamic hijab complete body covered
except the face and hands up to the rest
and if they're walking down the streets
of Bombay maybe at ped Road or na
Road where we have many bird
watchers if they're walking down the
streets of ped Road on APC Road and if
around the corner there's a holigan
who's waiting for a catch who's Wai to
tease a girl I'm asking you the question
which girl will he tease will he tease
the girl wearing the miniskirt or shorts
or will it tease the girl wearing the
Islamic
hijab which girl will it
tease but natural the girl wearing the
Min skirt so Quran rightly says that
hijab has been prescribed for the women
so that they shall be recognized that
they're modest and will prevent them
from being molested after that the
Islamic Sharia says any man rapes any
woman he gets capital punishment death
penalty many non-muslims say death
penalty in this age of Science and
Technology in the 21st century Islam is
a barbaric religion it's a ruthless way
of
life but when you ask this question and
I've asked this question to thousands of
non-muslim Muslims that God forbid
suppose someone rapes your mother or
someone rapes your sister and if you are
meet the judge and if the rapist is Bor
in front of you what punishment will you
give to that rapist and believe me
100% 100% of the non-muslims they said
we will put him to
death some went to the extreme of saying
we will torture him to
death there was only one smart Al when I
went to USA
he told me the brother
Zakir I will give him five years
imprisonment I said
fine then I told him that according to
the statistics of America out of those
people who are convicted for rape and
they are given imprisonment when they
come out 95% rape again so if you want
your mother to be raped again you're
most welcome we Muslims don't want
that so he told me if that's the casee
then I would give him death penalty as
the first
shot today America we look up to America
as the most advanced country in the
world do you know it is a country which
has one of the highest rate of rape
according to the statistics of the FBI
1990 alone every day
1,756 rapes took
place again repeated in 1996 it says
that every day on average
2,713 cases of rape place in America
that means every 32 second one rap is
taking place in
America we are here for one and a half
hour already more than 100 R have taken
place in America since the time we are
here I'm asking you the question that if
you implement the Islamic Sharia in
America that any man looks at a woman if
any unashamed thought comes in his mind
he should lower his gaze after that
every woman she should be modestly D
complete body covered except the face
and hands up to the rest and after that
if any man rapes a woman he gets capital
punishment death penalty I'm asking you
the question will the rate of rape in
America will it increase will it remain
the same or will it
decrease it will decrease easy question
easy
answer you don't have to be a scholar to
know this you implement the Sharia and
you get results
but because Islam gives the solution it
does not go down the throat
but a few years ago the home minister of
India elk adwani he had said in the
Parliament and he proposed that in India
also there should be death penalty for
the rapist and I congratulate him for
that I may not agree with his other
policies but as far as this policy is
concerned I agree with him that death
penalty for the
rapist maybe the next home minister will
say that every woman in India should
have the hijab on inshallah
if you want no rape to take place in
India anywhere in the world whether it
be America UK you implement the Sharia
you'll get results immediately that's
the reason the least rate of rape in any
country in the world it's in Saudi
Arabia any country which implements the
Islamic Sharia whatever part they
Implement they get results whatever part
they don't Implement they don't get
results today we find that the religion
of Islam it is said to be a religion
which degrades the women which
subjugates the
women for the complete answer you can
refer to my video cassette women's
rights in Islam time does not permit me
to speak in
detail but if you analyze
today the Western Society claiming to
uplift the woman is actually they're
degrading the women the Western talk of
women's liberalization is is nothing but
a disguise form of deprivation of Honor
degrading a soul as well as exploitation
of a body the Western Society claiming
to uplift the woman have actually
degraded her to a status of concubine
Mystic and Society butterflies which are
mere tools in the hands of Pleasure
Seekers hidden behind the colorful
screen of art and culture in the name of
art and culture and women's
liberalization what is the Western world
doing they are selling our daughters
they're selling our mothers they're
selling our sisters and
India after a few years what the Western
Country does we find India is following
that follow the good things I've got no
problem you know when I was in
school more than 20 years
back most of the newspapers they were
clean you could hardly
find any obscene photographs but now if
you pick up any newspaper whether
leading newspaper Daily Newspaper most
of them almost all they have to have
obscene photographs in
it even on the sports page what do they
have football star then they show the
girlfriend what has the girlfriend going
to do with
football they want to sell the paper
women's
liberalization ronaldino what the name I
don't know all the names of the football
stars and then they show the girlfriend
then you find a cricketer and then they
show the girlfriend so even on the
sports page if there's no news of wom
then they show the girlfriend invariably
all the newspapers and many newspapers
have
supplements supplements like Times of
India the most famous newspaper it the
largest selling English newspaper of the
world largest selling Daily newspaper of
the world it has supplement got Bombay
times and people of Bombay know what is
Bombay times famous for especially page
number
three and this was a strategy and I do
agree after getting the
strategy the sale of times of India has
increased I'm not against Times of India
only I'm talking about times of India
because that's the paper I read daily
you talk about any other newspaper DNA
Hindustan times Indian times up or down
less or more you'll find these women who
are semi nude in the name of women's
liberalization so I us to tell my
vendor my newspaper man that only give
me times of India I don't want Bombay
times he's saying free free move off me
I said if you give me Bombay times I
won't pay you
money he's telling me free free don't
worry sir it is free I said I don't want
it only give me the main newspaper that
I mentioned a few years back but today
even in the main newspaper you have
women either on the sports page either
on international news either on the font
page somewhere there you'll find no
wonder the selling of most of the
newspapers have
increased and we find in the name of
women liberalization in the name of art
and
culture in ads you'll find most of the
ads have got
women if you see an ad of a motorcycle
whether it be abroad or whether it be in
India how many women ride motorcycle how
many percentage less than
1% in India less than 1 person abroad
also but invariably in a motorcycle ad
you'll find a woman For
What and I was told about the very
famous BMW ad know BMW car is very
famous the BMW car the car which has a
status is Mercedes but for the
youngsters the BMW is famous it has a
good pickup it's a faster car so someone
told
me that one of the ads of BMW it had a
girl in a bikon in front of the car and
the caption was test drive her now who
the girl of the
car what are we
doing are you selling your daughters
your mothers your sisters Islam does not
believe in such kind of liberalization
if you say this is liberalization we
happy with what we
are we love our sisters we love our
mothers we love our wives we love them
we respect them and we want to protect
them and we give them equal rights for
more details about rights of women in
Islam refer to my video Cass said
women's rights in
Islam I would like to end my
talk by trying to clarify the last
misconception that Islam was sped by the
sword if you translate peace was sped by
the
sword peace was sped by The Sword and
you have noticed that in the exhibition
in the panels we had certain common misn
noas common Mis Nomas like the World is
Flat you have a
square triangle 2 + 2 is equal to five
Islamic
terrorism it's the
same how the world is not flat it's a
common misn NOA 2 plus 2 is not equal to
5 similarly Islam and terrorism is
exactly the
opposite but it's a very common
misconception and the reply was given
very well by Dei oeri a very famous
historian in the book Islam at the
Crossroad number eight and he says
that history makes it clear that the
legend of fanatical Muslims sweeping
across the world foring Islam at the
point of the sword is the most fantastic
absurd myth that historians have ever
repeated it is the most
repeated and we know from history that
we
Muslims We Rule Spain for about 800
years we did not force anyone the point
of the neither did we r a message we
didn't conve the message later on the
Crusaders came they wiped up the Muslims
there was not a single Muslim who could
openly give the
aan if we wanted we could have forced
everyone to accept Islam as the point of
the S but we didn't do it we
Muslims the Arabs we have been the lord
of the Arab lands for the past 1400
years years for a few years the
britishers came for the few years the
French came but overall we have been the
lord of the Arab land for the past 400
years yet today there are more than 14
million Arabs who are Coptic Christians
Coptic Christians means the Christians
in Generations these 14 million Arab
Coptic Christians they are giving
shahada they are bearing witness that
Islam wasn't Spar at the point of the
sword we Muslims we rule this great
country India for A Thousand Years the
muls if we wanted we could have forced
every Indian to accept Islam at the
point of the sord but we didn't do it
today more than 80% Indians they are
non-muslims these 80% non-muslim Indians
they are giving shahada they are bearing
witness that Islam wasn't spare at the
part of the
sword today the country which has the
largest population of Muslim in
Indonesia which army went to IND IIA
which army went to Malaysia which has
more than 50% Muslims which army went to
the east coast of Africa which sword the
sword of the intellect as Allah says in
the Quran in chapter number 16 verse
number
125 invite all to the way of th Lord
with wisdom and beautiful preaching and
argue with them and reason with them in
the ways that are best most gracious it
is the sword of the intellect which is
Conquering the hearts
it's not the sword of steal it is the
sword of reasoning and understanding
which is winning over people according
to an
article which came in the plain truth
magazine which was repeated in the
reader Al maner book 1984 it gave the
statistics of the increase in the major
world religions in a span of 50 years
from 1934 to
1984 and number one religion which
increased the maximum was Islam
235% Christianity only
47% I'm asking the question which war
took place in the span of 50 years from
1934 to 1984 which forced millions of
human being to accept Islam which war
which sword is a sord of intellect sword
of reasoning today according to
statistics the fastest going religion in
America in USA is Islam the fastest
going religion in Europe is Islam I'm
ask the question who is forcing these
Americans to accept
Islam who is forcing the Europeans to
accept Islam and when the media says
that Islam is subjugating the woman do
you know out of those people who are
accepting Islam in the world about 23
more than 65% they are women more than
65% who accepting Islam in America they
are women more than 65% who are
accepting Islam in Europe they are women
I'm asking you the question if if Islam
subjugates the women then why are the
American women accepting Islam why are
the European women accepting Islam why
are the Indian women accepting Islam
why because Islam has the solution for
the problem of
womankind they have seen the world when
they see the world they find that Islam
is the only solution for the problems of
womankind and today we find as I
mentioned earlier that there is virent
propaganda about
Islam on the media we
find that they are spreading
misconception
but the more they doing
that we find after
911 this has reached epidemic
levels writing the against Islam
misconception about Islam the propaganda
against Islam increased but I believe in
the of the Quran of Iman chapter number
3 verse number 54 Where Allah
says that they PL and plotted Allah too
planned Allah is the best of
planners after 911 the amount of
propaganda they're doing against Islam
do you know after
911 the spread of Islam has
increased only in a span of 10 months in
USA alone after 9911 more than 34,000
Americans accept
Islam in Europe
alone more than 22,000 accepted Islam in
10 months time after 911
and I go to Europe I go to UK very often
I go to America and I find that after
911 when I give talks there are more
Americans coming for my talk there are
more Europeans coming for my
talk it's good they want to know what
kind of religion is this some come to
attack some come to learn we welcome
both of them we welcome both of them I
like
people who attack with reasoning I love
them and we know Omar may Allah be
pleased with him was one of the stest
enemy of Islam and the prophet paid for
his he got then he became one of the
stest supporters of
Islam that's the reason when Muslim
youngsters say that death to Doge Bush I
said don't say death to George Bush say
may Allah give to George
Bush and we
find that the more they attacking Islam
the more Islam is spreading see after
911 the crowd is increasing even here
and we find even in mombay non-muslims
are coming previously we used to give
chance to anyone to ask a question since
the last few years in my talks
non-muslim first
preference but the Muslims complain that
they never get a
chance and even today inshallah the
first chance will be non-muslims only
inshallah Allah gives the promise in the
Glorious Quran and no less than three
different places in Surah CH number 9
vers number 33 in Sur 48 verse number 28
as well as in Sur 61 vers number
n Allah has sent his messenger with
guidance and ReliOn of Truth so that it
will prevail over all the other ways of
life over all the
isms however much the disbel don't like
it and enough is Allah is a witness this
Dean this religion of Peace submitting a
will to almighty God is the only
solution for the problems of humankind
I'd like to end my talk with the
quotation of the Glorious Quran from
Surah Al Imran chapter number 3 verse
number 19 which
says ISL Allah the Creator in this last
and final Revelation says
thatl the only way of life the only
religion acceptable in the sight of
almighty God is peace acquired by
submitting your will to Almighty
godd